bella thorne steps out with Tyler Posey
could they be a new couple I don't
really know the 18 year old actress was
spotted with the 24 year old actor on
Saturday night leaving dinner at Katsuya
in downtown LA it was actually a lot of
fun
Bella showed quite a bit of skin in a
lacy black crop top paired with
high-waisted skinny jeans a leather
jacket and ankle booties Tyler kept a
casual and a white t-shirt black jeans
and sneakers
I witnessed lzt the long time pals
appeared to be more than friends noting
that they entered the restaurant holding
hands and quote couldn't stop smiling
and laughing together I just got lucky
it's not the first time the duo has been
romantically linked fans speculated they
were possibly dating last year which
Bella shot down on Twitter who is your
celebrity crush grateful kids Bella and
Greg dated for over a year but announced
their split last month which begs the
question could Bella and Tyler be eating
up as a new couple let us know your
thoughts over on Twitter at DT now